you know and welcome to this video
yeah let's do it Oh unions Oh new color
okay
but many 2,000 players at the moment
here I don't know I was playing a bit of
blitz before I started them the video
recording again you just had stronger
higher rated or positional it's a bit
surprising okay anyway we have Bishop c5
here and scotch phone night that is a
sideline that is playable for black
probably not 100% satisfactory but it is
on the playable option oh yeah rook e8
is a bit more dangerous and tactical
pretty tactical line okay whenever they
in any sort of scotch structure whenever
they play with d6 that always a smile
really that's always for me the signal
to to play with long castles and g4 h
for golf on attack he has to take III I
mean be takes Bishop g5 you can resign
straight away you know okay 98 now leads
to nothing to take here and now the
question is something slowish or just
you had just aged voice good never
ending age five
if I go h5 maybe g5 so this first
[Music]
let's take here first
and now what to do next the H file is
open I can go f4 Knight said somewhere
and queen h3 it already looks pretty
awful and pretty awful is a bit of a
euphemism it looks completely dead queen
h7 mate what's the deal them if he puts
the Queen on the 70s twin edge a true H
7 winning the Queen at least maybe I got
more but I'll be ok with the winner of
the Queen Jared's
completely reasonable
[Music]
okay we can take here I'll then take at
hive just one day if there is something
better if I take on f5 for Luke for
rookie one yeah it's actually also
pretty good opening up the Evo
[Music]
yeah just win material I don't know
almost almost any move now wins huge
chunks of material it's one of them
okay the queen is still not hanging
I mean rook takes rook shakes and still
just queen evade available and now I
don't know many moves probably win maybe
95 was the way to do it but okay nice it
has the rook hanging and the night
hanging went to keep her for me should
make things a bit easier he's got one
check here
like when you three check actually Queen
III check that's a dude but didn't
didn't see that
okay so yeah let's have a look it was a
basically not playable position if black
plays like that I think you should play
rook e8 now and try to make this work
this leads to very sharp complications
starting with this and really really
complicated here Aronian against Kramnik
sacrificed the queen with 90 x III and
that led to a slight advantage Freud
okay in the game d6 f3 gentium I think
black is really not enjoying life so
much I have a very simple plan I mean if
you compare white this position exactly
like in the Sicilian Dragon I have this
G for age for automatic attack and black
has no counter play there is no open sea
for nothing
g6 however is a bit of a shocking move
to be honest it just weakens the King
side tremendously yeah so here he has to
take that is over merely as a deadly pen
so this and it's it's it's an automatic
attack just you just push everything
forward and waiting nothing nothing much
really that that black can do him I
probably missed quicker wins but this is
dis efficient Queen g6 of course most
possible okay the way they came turned
out it was a would never resign no
matter what I do age 795 is made yeah
yeah
yes I saw the idea 95 perpetual 8 you
don't really look at how
that much material and I hadn't missed
though that wasn't so great yeah Queen
III is slightly annoying because this is
not a good idea makes the game
interesting again so I have to go to d1
and after this I have to go this way
which is yeah not a real problem but you
have to it's more uncomfortable than
then really was necessary at all okay
guys thanks for watching